hi my name is Evie and today we're gonna
be talking about algorithms that teach
you math so before we get started I just
want to take a step back and talk about
how do humans think about math how do we
solve math so here's some math this is
an expression that could be simplified
and when I look at this and probably
same for many of you I without even
really thinking much about it know that
8 divided by 4 happens first Division
has precedence over subtraction or for
something like this I know I don't even
have to do the work if 8 divided by 4
the - 8 / 4s cancel each other out and
so I'm making patterns about math in my
mind and the question we're gonna be
talking about is like how can we get an
algorithm or a computer to do these same
patterns and that's what I was thinking
about and my internship at a company
called Socratic they make a homework
help app and I'm how people answer their
homework questions and when I joined
they were adding math support and so
they wanted a solver that could simplify
expressions or solve equations and do
that step-by-step and these were some
goals we had for a step by step solver
so it should be detailed so not just
here's the answer but also you know all
the ways that you get there and I'm
having good explanations not just what
the steps are but why and it should feel
intuitive so the things that the
algorithm comes up with should be
something similar to what a human might
come up with not just some weird answer
that gets you there and nothing was free
and opensource and focused on teaching
and so we built our own algorithm and
the app using it look kind of like this
at the end of my internship which was a
year and a half ago so I don't know what
it looks like now but it's called
Socratic cool so how do you build a
step-by-step mouse-over you might be
wondering and we're gonna get into that
all right so you get some ASCII math
text input that is parsed into a tree
that tree is simplified a bunch of times
that's like the step by step part until
eventually the algorithm decides that
there is nothing left to simplify and
then it's done
and so what does that mean
so parsing the ASCII math here's an
example of some ASCII math it's just a
string of characters I think this is
kind of neat like in a book when you
read a book there's a lot of characters
on the page but then you're putting them
into like words and sentences and
paragraphs and ideas and similarly here
there's just a bunch of characters but
like I know that minus three is the
argument to the function absolute value
or like the multiplication part has
higher precedence and that's kind of
more grouped together than the
subtraction part and but the algorithm
also needs to be able to think about
things like this so we need to make it a
bit more formal with trees so this is
what it looks like in a parse tree as
you can see the minus 3 it's an argument
to the absolute value function the
multiplication part is kind of like more
tightly grouped together than
subtraction part because that has like
higher precedence and so all that
information is in there and this is a
tree that you can get if you use math
j/s and they have this great purse
function and then does this we get a
tree and so we use that tree computer
algebra systems also use trees and
computer algebra systems are just like
computers that do like calculators that
do like really fancy math including
simplifying math and I was thinking oh
there's this popular computer algebra
system called simp I what and it can
simplify math so what if I just go into
the code and like have it show its work
because like it does some work why don't
we just use that work as the step by
step and then I looked at their parse
tree and it looked like this
so like X minus y plus 2/3 was then X
plus minus 1 times y plus 2 times 3 to
the minus 1 which is yeah the same kind
of thing but also not how are you doing
this
but it turns out that subtraction and
division are kind of annoying for the
steps they wanted to take to get to the
answer and they only care about getting
to the answer
so like the goals of the computer
algebra system was different from our
goals which is the step by step solution
and this tree isn't really helpful for
getting to the step by step solution
because it immediately like gets rid of
all of what the user was asking so we
designed our own tree
and part of designing our own tree was
we had to think about this arithmetic
operations or binary thing which I had
never thought about before like I know
that subtraction is binary definitely
has two arguments Division is binary but
addition I was I was like oh yeah that's
like adding three numbers together but
no 2 plus 3 plus 4 is 2 plus 3 plus 4 or
2 plus 3 plus 4 and so the math j/s tree
that we got had all the addition was
binary but because addition and also
multiplication are commutative and
associative binary operations they feel
like they don't need to be binary but
they could have any number of arguments
so I think of additions more as like the
tree on the right and not the tree on
the left and that is what the tree looks
like and the math steps algorithm and
it's useful for things like this or you
want to collect and combine like terms
so like oh look there are two x's we can
add those things together like that's
pretty useful in algebra and simplifying
expressions and it turns out it's like
way harder to do that when they're all
spread out in the tree but if they're
all the same child of the same plus node
then it's a lot easier to find those
things to collect and combine together
alright so we have a parse tree next
step we want to simplify it step by step
ooh baby you got it get to you girl yeah
so here are some examples of simplifying
rules so like something to the 0
becoming one or adding two numbers
together or you know adding the bottom
is like collect and combining like terms
there's like a whole bunch of these I
thought that math was like pretty
intuitive and then I realized how much
things you have to consider at any point
and I was like oh man math is actually
pretty hard I understand what why
everyone thinks this and the way that
these rules are applied is through tree
search so for example with this rule you
would look the tree find an exponent
node does it have 0 as the exponent if
so just replace that whole thing with 1
and I know that 0 to the 0 is undefined
but that could be like handled somewhere
else with exceptions and that's pretty
much how all of the rules are applied
in some order and some things applied
before others but that's the algorithm
but the algorithm has limitations and I
want to talk about those limitations for
example different people salt and that's
differently one example of this is just
how many steps do people need so if
someone doesn't really know what's going
on adding more details might be useful
or else they like won't be able to
understand the solution at all but for
other people you show them like 30 steps
and they're like whoa that's too hard
and scary like I don't want to look at
that that's too much and they're
overwhelmed for other people they might
just be kind of like bored if you show
them a bunch of steps and they already
know how most of that works so how many
steps you show depends on the problem
but it also depends on the person and
this algorithm doesn't take the input of
like the person and that's a hard
problem there's no like best way of
solving something and there's no best
way of teaching something and massdep's
is like here's the way we do it which is
how we elgar them-- was designed but it
means it's not perfect also a stuff I
stopped solution isn't like a full
teaching tool so like it shows how
something can be done but it's not a
lesson plan with like a full depth
explanation of why everything is
happening so chronic does a pretty good
job of using the math steps algorithm in
their app and it's really helpful and
lots of people give Socratic 5-star
reviews saying that it helped them
figure out math problems and they also
get a lot of five-star reviews ever
different kind about how people love
using it to cheat because students gonna
cheat and I can talk a whole bunch
another time about how the education
system makes me sad but you know it's
important I think to like realize that
step by step by step solutions can be
used for this and like the implications
of making something like that there's
also lots of really cool things you
could do with something like math steps
for example the algorithm like given
let's say like adding fractions together
the way it comes up with those steps is
because it can tell that you're adding
fractions together it's like oh here are
two fractions now we're going to be the
steps for adding fractions but if it
knows you're adding fractions Nick it
can now give you a video about how to
add fractions and that makes it a little
bit more of a full learning experience
or what if it knows that you're adding
actions together and your friend is
adding fractions together and now you
can add fractions together together
because community is like a really great
way to learn things and like you can
teach things to your friends and that's
like a really great like learning tool
as two people talk to your friends about
what you're doing this one I really like
is you make them guess what's happening
next so that they actually have to like
think about the next step but I kind of
feel like a lot of students maybe
wouldn't want to do this sadly but I
think that it would be a really great
teaching tool because all the steps are
there they could guess and then you
could tell them whether they're right or
not or how their thing differs or any
many other things some things that I
have been thinking about that I didn't
have time to talk about today maybe some
things that you just thought of I'd love
to talk about that you're welcome to
check it out there is a demo I'll post
these slides on Twitter and you can see
what kinds of stuff it does it does not
solve all math but it solves some things
and you can also check out the source
code because it's open source and
there's lots of documentation I'm not
really actively maintaining and
maintaining the project right now but
there's lots of stuff in there I'd love
to talk about it if you have any
questions and or about anything and that
is alguns a teaching math
[Applause]